uh it's a pleasure to introduce the next
speaker Ben will continue uh preaching
on economics part four
okay so let me tell you what today is
going to be
I'm gonna I'm gonna quickly finish
um I'll have a very short unit finishing
what we learned about Network
coordination games I want to just build
up to a basic idea which for people with
the math inclination is very
um I think
shows you how powerful your techniques
are in a place where there's fairly low
hanging fruit how you can do welfare
analysis using quadratic forms I want to
tell you about a different area this
will be the briefest little chapter
where we'll talk about financial
networks and how payment clearing works
and how you can model Financial
um distress and the contagion of it
using models very very ones now by now
that you will have had a lot of feeling
for including epidemic models and then
finally and the part that I'm most
excited about today is a is a section on
production networks
which is about percolation and
discontinuous phase transitions in a
complex production economy so that's a
paper that was just published that I'm
involved in but it's it's something that
I I'm super excited to talk to this
audience about it because I think it
um
has a lot of potential to connect with
graph on ideas in a much richer way than
we've done so far but it already shows
you that very kind of like exactly the
core I think interest Center of this
group which is you know
graphons and and limits of large
networks can interact with economics in
a very rich way and again there's
low-hanging fruit that I think I'm
excited about I hope I can get you
excited about
so
this is where we left off at the end of
last time um if if you you know this
slide is so this will only be about 20
minutes if you weren't if you weren't um
there at the end of last time don't
worry but this slide is actually
self-contained we were studying a
network coordination game where
individual payoffs were given by a loss
for miscoordinating with others wij is
the weight describing how much I care
about coordinating with Jay there was a
a term describing how much I dislike
Miss coordinating with my favorite
actions
and we studied this network game we
thought about what it means to have a
Nash equilibrium which means that the
actions I take are best responses to
other people's actions taking them as
fixed and then we ask what would it take
for such a system to be in equilibrium
we wrote out the equilibrium equations
we solved them that was no great feat
but we solved this system of linear
equations
we got an expression for for equilibrium
the equilibrium action Vector you can
think of it either this way or this
equivalent way
um
sorry about this there's an F missing
here so there should be you know this is
just this thing is another way of
writing the Matrix R and then there's an
F
and so the key Matrix that describes how
action how favorite actions are
aggregated into equilibrium actions is r
and we saw a picture of that now
hopefully the picture will be uh I just
want to remember I set up I set up
favorite Point disagreement in a
particular way
uh this way and then I said equilibrium
actions were going to be something that
effectively Smooths this and of course
if you by the way if you if you like
probability
this is closely related to
um
you can think of this as basically
taking this kind of boundary condition
and doing some kind of walk and how you
know what what action a person takes is
in some sense the expected end point of
a walk uh is you know the what gets
absorbed with some geometric stopping
time and so there's a connection by the
way equilibrium actions look like this
now we know everything about how they
how they uh are made we know about what
determines equilibrium actions as beta
goes to one when people care about
coordinating a lot the action Vector
converges to a constant Vector which is
exactly the constant consensus that we
had in the group so the weight that
someone has in determining the final
consensus is their eigenvector
centrality in the graph that people
updated or coordinated here but more
generally you can ask about this away
from beta equals one you won't have
consensus you'll have some richer
pattern of behavior like we just saw and
I will actually interrupt the turn off
toggle because it's a nightmare if it
keeps saying that
um you can also ask not just about limit
Behavior but you can ask about
average Behavior away from the beta
equals one limit you can ask a very
similar question like if I change Mr I's
favorite Point how much will that affect
the total action maybe you care about
total effort if this is effort in school
or in you know Financial due diligence
or what have you and so you can ask if I
change Mr I's favorite Point how much is
that going to affect every the total of
everybody's effort well that turns out
to be given just by the column sums of
this Matrix R so the column the ith
column sum is the centrality of that
agent it says how important they are in
determining average Behavior so there's
a and this is a slightly different
centrality measure from eigenvector it's
closely related it's sociologists also
studied it in particular bonus study
that uh before anybody studied these
Network games so that's the basic theory
of these games it was actually developed
by these three
um in an econometric paper in o6 that of
course did more than just this but a
paper I love is a is a fox paper by bko
bindel kleinberg and Oren
in which they made and this answers a
question that Christian brought up um
not to feel free but I I Christian
brought up a
it made a
broken
Christian asked you know
we might not just want to take the
system and study its equilibrium as a
magic point that somehow reached
automatically you might want to study
how people get there so when bko made
explicit is they said well what if
people myopically best respond what does
that mean it means they start with their
favorite actions because that's all they
know at the beginning of time and then
every period they look around and they
respond optimally to what they see going
on in their neighborhood so that's kind
of a national process I just look I
here's what my friends are playing let
me just respond to that why is it myopic
because I'm not anticipating how they'll
adjust today I'm just taking what they
did yesterday and it's predictive of
what they've been doing today
you can write that Dynamic so they
optimize against their players last
period actions their next period action
will then be a weighted average of
their current their friends current
actions uh and then they'll always wait
their favorite point because it's always
in their payoff and so this is a process
which is actually a degree like Dynamic
it was studied by two other guys
friedkin and Johnson
it's like the group with a persistent
opinion here uh you can imagine that
it's the group but everybody has a mom
at home and every day this mom says the
same thing and so you're never gonna you
know degrude converges everybody the the
only the initial opinions mixed together
and everybody ultimately somehow
reconciles but here you know in this
process the moms always say the same
thing so I won't reconcile that's why
you see you know the process converges
somewhere and actually where it
converges to is the equilibrium action
profile of the game and actually for
this game is so nice that any reasonable
Dynamic you can put any adjustment
process which is at all sensible will
lead you to this limit the you know the
rationalizable sets converge down to
this limit so this is one simple Dynamic
but it recovers bko pointed out that
this purely mechanical sociology process
is recovered as a myopic best reply
dynamic in this game yes Christian
which we had at some point
this seems to indicate even though you
have sort of the global equilibrium
that there's some way to reach it
locally yes and that seems to indicate
maybe the global Network structure might
be not that important here and this
might hold if you have a video of the
limit or something like that to sort of
push that exactly exactly so this this
is a very good in this process if you
just look at it but you know this maybe
it's clear as for writing the
equilibrium in the you know when we
wrote the equilibrium it had this and
I'll describe that as the things that
came around
just from staring at this with beta less
than one you can kind of see that in any
there's a locality to this process right
and and you can say what happens
actually very much unlike the degree
process because in the degree process
there might be something almost at
Infinity which is going to ultimately
have huge influence but here you know
people who can only you know once we get
a what you can uniformly bound the
effects of far away stuff
um if W is gov is governed by a graph
and so that there is this process will
work nicely with weak local uh limits I
think the future it's a great question
Jason
it related maybe um because I don't
fully speak fluently the language of
Greek local limits and graphs yet but
when you say that this is sort of my
myopic best response is that
um simply related to or just literally
equivalent to saying that this is like a
first order approximation of Dynamics
because it looks to me this is just like
the partial
yeah
right
so this system remember this game is
rigged to be totally linear so actually
there's no question of approximating the
Dynamics because the Dynamics are just
rigged to be as linear now there is a
great question though people do of
course want to generalize this to
non-linear versions of this game because
you should probably only believe this as
an approximation you know maybe your
game is smooth so it's locally linear
and so how does how do game Dynamics
converge outside of the linear case
there's actually some nice work on that
Francesca has done a very nice work on
that using
um why don't you say
variational inequalities to to Really
push beyond the linear case and kind of
get as much of the intuitions
as we can from that extending to more
general settings right so yeah my
question kind of is like in this case
the myopic response is kind of the full
Dynamics because it just is linear but
in other cases is the myopic response
just the linear approximate is that what
it's defined it's so yeah I think there
is a way of thinking of it like that
that you kind of take a fixed yeah to
the extent that these people are
adjusting those terms if they're
adjusting slowly you might hope there's
sort of second order as well so there I
think there is an analogy though I don't
I'm hesitant to uh but it seems it seems
like a reasonable guess so I don't
unfortunately given that I do want to
cover a lot today I won't talk through
every row of this table but there's an
obvious analogy which I've already been
emphasizing between the degree and the
coordination game setting
I've emphasized that the asymptotic
outcome whereas integrated with just a
number a consensus that everybody
reaches here that's a vector of
equilibrium actions which is richer
um you in the group if we wanted to talk
about not consensus we had to take time
you know we had to stop time before we
converge here we can actually just look
at a coordination parameter beta that's
away from one and you'll have diversity
of behavior
um and so and then there's a influence
metric that before it was eigenvector
centrality here it's a different
centrality but it's obviously analogous
and finally and this is something I said
yesterday or last lecture and want to
repeat whereas in in degree or fried
conjunction Theory there's ad hoc
measures of disagreement or polarization
that you just write down because they
seem interesting to you on kind of
primitive grounds here
because people have preferences you can
get Welfare grounded measures of
outcomes so if whatever you you think is
important in this case well hopefully it
should be whatever you think is
important about these these um actions
for people's payoffs should presumably
be in their utility functions and then
you can ask you know what will be the
welfare consequences of some
intervention and so there's a lot of
work actually going on now which I like
a lot um there's uh Mickey Raj for
example uh has has papers studying
um how you would modify a network and uh
there's I'm trying to think actually
kleinberg with other co-authors Gaetan
de kleinberg and tardosh have have
papers on this stuff but I really it
tends to often people still work in
these kind of ad hoc mechanical
processes and just say oh we want to
minimize polarization and I think what
the economic approach really has to add
it's very powerful for disciplining
research programs because we can ask a
bunch of questions that are you don't
you don't need any taste to ask good
questions in a sense you can just ask
what would be a more efficient outcome
how can we change the environment to
improve people's welfare and that gives
that grounds things in a way that
economists have found very helpful
so
one obvious question and I'll be brief
on this one but it's a beautiful it's
the bko paper answers the question of to
what extent are people's is people's
selfishness harmful in this setting
because in equilibrium people take
actions without considering the
implications for others and so you can
ask how bad is that it turns out the
answer will be not that bad and it's a
beautiful result at least under
conditions not that bad then you can ask
if actually we do something you know
more socially relevant question perhaps
is
um if someone out there can manipulate
us either you know give us a change our
opinions give us disagreements that we
maybe didn't have before which is
something that political campaigns do
all the time how would they do so
um for example to make a source office
they wanted to do that or to or to help
us you know cohere and be better off so
I'll give you a toy version of that for
mathematical intuition and briefly
mention you know a program on optimal
small interventions in Network games
changing people's opinions
um you know in a way that's intended to
facilitate their welfare so I'll give
you you know I'll be brief about this
but I want to give you a taste of how
powerful very simple math is in helping
us think more clearly about these things
so what did bko do they said take this
game they considered a little example to
begin with they said suppose favorite
points are zero half and one
they compute equilibrium actions with
beta equals a half
um and equilibrium actions turn out to
be a quarter a half and three quarters
so people compromise toward the middle
you know every the side guys compromise
toward their middle friend
but if you compute what a utilitarian
would do someone who cared about
maximizing
the sum of everybody's payoffs
utilitarian planner would actually push
them closer would make them go to a
third and two-thirds here so that so
utilitarian planner wants them to be
closer so bko and what's going on here
well when I compromise when I move
closer to Christian I do that to some
extent because it makes it's in my
welfare function but every time I move
closer to him it also makes him better
off and I don't care about that my
payoff a planner does so a planner would
would push us closer and that's why
utilitarian is closer in the above
example utilitarian social welfare at
the optimum can be computed at
equilibrium and Optimum at equilibrium
it's minus 3 8 at the utilitarian
outcome it's minus a third which is
better of course planner could always do
the Nash equilibrium will always do
better than that
bko showed that this example is in fact
worst
so they show that in any example with
undirected graphs which means the W
comes from a symmetric interaction by
normalizing it you know interaction in a
symmetric Network they show that the
worst it can be is that the social loss
of the equilibrium action profile will
be at most nine over eight times the
social loss of efficient
so the price of Anarchy here is small is
uh I don't know how these words work but
foreign
equilibrium doesn't hurt us that much
it kind of makes sense because you know
there's not any huge externality here
it's not as if
everybody wants others to take more
action or less action there's some loss
from not getting close enough to each
other but these guys show that in the
symmetric case in the undirected case is
bounded in the directed case it can get
arbitrarily bad did you do you have a
question
is this a unique equipment
there's only one equilibrium in this
world no that's a great question that's
I I failed I failed to say that but
there's one equilibrium you converge to
it it's the best ever and it makes it
easy to give talks and stuff
um so their proof technique is by
diagonalizing
diagonalizing the situation noticing
that in the stuff that determines
equilibrium and the stuff that
determines welfare is simultaneously
diagonalizable which lets you do algebra
that's very straightforward and I'll say
a little more about that at the end but
the moral here is that the
inefficiencies from selfishness are
limited and the inefficient the problem
with this environment is not so not that
we're somehow playing equilibrium and
not caring about each other's interests
in that sense but where the harm is
coming is just the fundamental
disagreements that are driving us to be
unhappy with our with our friends and so
that gives rise to a very natural
question which is if someone could mess
around with f how would they how would
they do so okay
and so let me give you a super toy
problem suppose you were an omnipotent
being with the power to just set
people's favorite actions so this is a
ridiculous problem but it will be
mathematically Illuminating
and so this should be I think this I
don't know if this is inequality okay so
one thing we can do for free is we can
demean these actions and assume they
have mean zero because this whole
situation is shifted variant and let
just take it on faith from me that
scaling F by a constant is just going to
affect welfare once you've demeaned
scaling affects welfare in a very simple
way so to understand what matters it
suffices to do it on on the sphere for
normalized f so really we can ask the
question with this game and now I'm
going to make a important simplification
I'm going to take G not to be just any
row stochastic Matrix but a symmetric
row stochastic Matrix so it's also
column stochastic that is a major
simplification it makes it so that in
terms of influence we're all equal
and for considering these second moment
questions of how much do we disagree it
makes things a lot easier
um it is a real it's it's by no means
without loss and it is I actually don't
know that people have fully understood
everything that how how things get
richer when you have both kinds of
things going on but let's assume that so
then suppose I just told you look you
have to allocate Norm one worth of
fundamental disagreement here
um how would you do it if you were if
you were Putin and you wanted to mess
with our society in order to make us as
unhappy as possible how would you do it
if you were Mary Poppins and you wanted
everybody you had to allocate this much
disagreement but you wanted to do it in
a benevolent way how would you do it
okay
the idea will be to write this problem
in a nice basis and use a kind of
Fourier approach okay what does that
look like let me just skip that so you
take your Matrix G and I'm going to
diagonalize it but I'm going to
diagonalize it in a flamboyantly visual
way
um
so remember my visual convention that
when I have a network I can depict any
function on the nodes in this way where
I color a node green if it's if the
positive entry read for a negative entry
and the size tells me how big that entry
is so now these are just
14 vectors on R14 and there are 14
players in this game and these vectors
of which I've emitted the middle ones
form a basis for R14 so any Vector
you're interested in the favorite
actions Vector the action Vector you can
write in this basis as a mix of these
guys
um
and
so for example I might set up the
favorite actions to be this with a
little bit of the second eigenvector and
the ordering is so this is the biggest
eigenvalue one this is the second
biggest this is a negative one the
lowest eigenvalue corresponding to this
this last eigenvector
just uh um from my own curiosity show of
hands who
who regards these kinds of spectral
graph basic spectral graph Theory
examples are somewhat familiar who's
bumped into them in some form okay
that's about what I hoped for and
expected so
um
here is the reason I introduced this
once you have this basis you can State
the answer to my question in a very
simple way
if you want to minimize these people's
welfare and hurt them as much as
possible subject to having this Norm one
worth of disagreement to allocate you
you the minimum is achieved by
setting up their disagreement to be
along the last the bottom eigenvector
setting it up to be like this and
moreover
the welfare you achieved that way the
disutility you can achieve for them
depends on the network only through the
last eigenvalue of the network this is
true not just for this little circle
example but for any network the only
thing that matters for how badly off you
can make them is the bottom eigenvector
according to a function that I could
write down for you explicitly but won't
okay but what what the lower the lower
the bottom eigenvalue the worse off you
can make them okay
so extrema welfare depends on G only
through its last eigenvalue and
oppositely if what you care about is
making these people happy and you can
set up disagreement but you again have
to allocate this much disagreement
you're going to allocate it according to
the second eigenvector the one
corresponding to the the spectral cut
one if you know that
um this is the best way and again the
welfare you can achieve is going to
depend only on the second eigenvalue
yeah I had I used to have it on the
slide the most important thing is it's
it's you know I'll just say Madison so
the lower it's a monotone function and
I'll tell you
um
I
I'll refer you to the paper to look at
it um it's a reasonable question I I
went for Less clutter but maybe
I
thought you know
I won't dare because I might make a
mistake at semester for this shape I
don't care
uh this is the eigenvalue
I mean it's modest so it's monotone so
the bigger the second there's always a
loss I guess so it's always negative
but something like this I think it
converted I think it's it's concave you
know because it has to when you when
these people when when you have a very
good split in your graph there's going
to be almost no this utility because
across the places where people disagree
they're not going to be attracted almost
at all so it'll be some kind of concave
increasing function of
fifth zero well yeah so as as oh and I
guess
someone is the biggest
so
you're saying that the image on the left
is kind of the worst case scenario
but so this book by the Agreements are
sort of organized like this you can
argue this Dynamic process and that
would lead to the most consensus very
good let me so hold that on that's
exactly that there is a tension here
which I wanna so normatively so first of
all this is not quite the normative
exercise I ultimately want to do it's
just to give you a little bit of
intuition but let's move toward actually
more realistic interventions so before
that I want to make so first of all I
did this in a circle I can do it in any
open here I've drawn a different network
and computed these two eigenvectors for
you same visual representation
I'll say this very quickly reminding you
of things you all know since by your
show of hands
um the bottom eigenvector is rigged to
maximize local heterogeneity if you'd
like it achieves a minimum if you think
about the Quran Fisher type of
characterization it achieves a minimum
of this kind of quadratic form it likes
to make neighbors opposite and it's
related to approximate two colorings
actually you might know the NFL player
Ravens player John Urschel turned
um
mathematician this is the stuff that he
he has a results kind of showing the
sense in which bottom eigenvectors
separate the graph into nodal domains
which are like you know the bottom one
is this really segregates the graph the
next one segregates it a little bit more
coarsely so you can look up he's kind of
the expert on this stuff
um second eigenvector is of course the
spectral clustering eigenvector it tries
to find a global cut and um the tension
that you pointed out which I want to
really stress is you could think of two
different especially combining this with
what we learned about the degree type
processes in the last lecture you know
um so
the there is some something I found
counter-intuitive so let me let me
Define two statistics of equilibrium
actions which you could be interested in
one is the covariance of two neighbors I
picked two people who are linked pick a
random Edge and look what's the
correlate what's the covariance of your
equilibrium actions I could do a
different exercise which is more like I
call this the New York Times exercise
you write an article saying how divided
we are you find like a farmer in Montana
and you know like a like a DJ in New
York and you say these guys are so
different okay so
um
this is taking the random pair and
looking at their covariance so
the favorite action Vector which
maximizes neighbor covariance makes
people harmonious in equilibrium with
their neighbors is U2 but it actually
minimizes uh sorry I guess I should say
it like this it it
minimizes the same Vector minimizes the
covariance of a random pair so if you
pick two random people it sustains as
much disagreement between them as
possible Right somehow the intuition is
that the F that maximizes local
disagreement
uh has the property that people converge
a lot toward their neighbors and that
attenuates the global the capacity of
the system to maintain disagreement
globally or conversely if you want to
make these people happy the way you set
it up is you allocate all the
fundamental disagreement among neighbors
but that disagreement's really good at
sticking around in a degree type process
so a network that would have if in in
the degree Theory a network that look
would have looked to you very segregated
and very bad at converging is actually
doing pretty well for its citizens on
this metric of the welfare and that kind
of suggests so what I'm pushing with
this is that you wouldn't necessarily
even thought about that being more of a
sort of you know just thinking cat when
certainly when I first thought casually
about this problem this seemed to me
like the important kind of disagreement
but it turned out that in another in a
sense the other kind is more important
and this relates of course to what
Nicole you know thinking about Nicole's
talk
this is about kind of finding
foundations for what makes people care
about their neighborhoods in some way or
another
um so I'll very briefly and informally
mention the the more serious targeting
problem you can think about imagine you
have a status quo Vector of favorite
actions that's what people actually like
to do and stuff and there's a little
Delta which you get to
introduce which is going to change
favorite actions in some way or another
and you have some cost function for this
intervention and you have a budget for
how much of it you can do and we care
about this optimization problem and
I'll tell you for for small budgets you
know you basically make assumptions so
that locally this looks like an L2
constraint so that this looks like doing
things in a small ball and when you can
prove is suppose you're malevolent okay
so the intuition from the previous part
survives it's your malevolent you show
up these people have some favorite
action you think aha what I'm gonna do
is I'm going to introduce a little bit
of last eigenvector
because that's what that's really that
contributes to their unhappiness so you
add you use all your power to change
things to add that kind of thing and
to the extent you could consider
introducing This Global eigenvector you
know makes the Republicans and the
Democrats even more divided than they
are but actually given how little they
interact in the network that's not going
to help the malevolent planner at all
and what's interesting is the benevolent
planner actually also cares about the
very same eigenvector benevolent planner
will find that flippy component of
disagreement and try to take it out if
there's any if there's any to be taken
out it'll say the best I can do is take
project everything onto that and try to
reduce that projection because that's
the welfare painful projection right so
you care these planners that what we
learned in this toy extremal exercise
applies to perturbation optimal
perturbation of f question that you and
I discussed last time is that you know
this is all taking the network is given
and perturbing F's and the question that
people are interested in now and I'll
just refer you there's a nice recent
paper by Mickey Raj which is and
co-authors unfortunately I forget as
co-authors but
um because I don't know them but this is
uh 21 I think they have papers in which
they think about Network perturbation
too to change the networks in a degree
like process with opinions you know or
opinions will be steered so this is a
pretty rich and active um literature in
kind of optimization
um and I think we don't yet have I think
things are quite clean if you think of
it as fixing the network and messing
with f how you optimally mess with the
network is much more conceptually open
but I think you know it's interesting
especially if you can find a way to make
the results
um nice and of course there's all sorts
of limit questions you can ask actually
you know one thing that I don't know
what one thing that's not so nice is
graph limits for the for the lowest for
this guy who knows what this looks like
when you you know what an appropriate
limit notion of this is so that's a set
of of math questions uh
okay I get very excited but I have to I
have to so one tiny word about how poofs
work you already have all seen this in
your head right so what you do is when
you diagonalize the system governing the
the equilibrium equation becomes
diagonal it splits into these decoupled
pieces along the eigen components what's
special about the eigen components is
that the equilibrium action in a certain
component is fully determined by the the
favorite action projection in that same
component so underlying here means in
the diagonalized basis and so I can just
boil everything down to these
amplification factors when I introduce
some variation along this axis of in the
eigen basis of fundamental disagreement
how does that translate into A's and
then everything I care about like the
welfare I can write as nice quadratic
forms which are just sums of n numbers
uh in the in the suitable components of
fundamental disagreement and so this is
you know people always bug me and say
this is so you know you all you
discovered diagonalizing a matrix you
know
can publish your paper here okay but uh
you I usually have to do a little more
but I think I think it's actually
amazing that this that the things
economists cared about anyway like
utilitarian welfare can be written as
the simplest possible quadratic forms
and making these optimization problems
quite trivial it usually means you can
push your analysis you know further than
you could otherwise I encourage you to
play with this yes
well the millennial wants to amplify it
by adding some U.N and then another one
wants to take the sort of the target is
the closed neighborhood as opposed to
exactly so I just want to find a little
bit hard to understand conceptually is
that
by making uh communities more homophilus
in terms of their opinion actually leads
to higher overall
um societal utility which I guess maybe
it's a
that's very counterintuitive and I don't
play of course I don't think this is the
real welder else which I probably left
out some stuff in my welfare function
we're in my model of the behavior like
once we split apart maybe people will
stop paying attention to the other side
at all and that will lead to social to
political unrest through terms I haven't
included in my payoff so I certainly am
not advocating this as serious welfare
analysis I'm saying there's this
component from the coordination part and
it needs to be it in any kind of Network
game analysis you're going to do it's
going to play a role what role it plays
so okay so go ahead can you
exactly so you end up you end up it's
just that ultimately welfare is a sum of
the squares of the components of the
favorite action Vector you see what you
call free analysis right new basis and
then you talk to coefficient exactly and
the coefficients that's somehow the core
of the
um okay so why is set up so can you give
us some intuition
so why is it just a function of mobile
to accept intuitive is that it's not
that it could be excited it's because it
the core fact is that welfare can be
written in terms of inner products I can
write the even in the original basis you
can write social welfare as an inner
product having to do with actions and
favorite points and once you have inner
products when you change basis you can
you know inner products are preserved by
orthonormal Transformations so that
allows you to get rid of all the cross
of all the diagonal terms
why would you
please I could see a sign of L if you
somewhere inside of your Matrix
appearing and then you died velocity
well deciding I mean the sign of the
Matrix when you write there's a certain
Matrix quadratic polynomial that the
term results there and that Matrix
quadratically has some coefficients
those coefficients ultimately
in some sense people get it from this a
l uh this uh audience called diagonalize
string things one minus beta I think it
will essentially again
this is non-linear but not just kind of
excited yeah yeah so so why right what
is in that's a good question I would
love to because I would push on and I
will I will uh certainly answer you
offline it's a good question why can the
function what is the function inside
but I don't know what it is
or do you have to stop the function this
looks like the simplest problem
everything should be sort of a platform
yes
I should be a problem
yeah that's a good question let me I
think it may I think it is actually a
quadratic function but I'll come back
because he also normalized the case
basis
okay reference for all this stuff in
this paper
this paper uh and paper papers with the
same co-authors and in fact I've gotten
really excited about this stuff so I'm
applying this to study optimal taxes in
a kind of Market game where these nodes
are firms and I think if I give a
workshop talk at the end of November at
the end of the Simon's Institute my
workshop talk will be about Market games
um spectral what's the punch line I
think for Applied mathematicians
spectral methods come with a great deal
of theory that smart people have
developed so if you're interested in
methods for optimization or
approximation you can take brilliant
work on graphons svms whatever bring it
to bear on your Network game analysis
and I think that you'd be you'd be
shocked by how how prehistoric uh some
of you know we in economics can be about
making the most of those tools and I'm
trying to build you know
um portholes to enable the use of those
tools but now I will switch to part two
the financial networks part and I thank
Matt Elliott my Microsoft who I started
working with when uh in Christians
Christian and Jennifer's Lab at
Microsoft and um
we've had a fruitful collaboration and
he's he's played a huge role in helping
um including in the teaching of this and
these are a lot of these are his slides
so
Financial net so Switching gears
completely not Network games Financial
networks here the interactions will be
through owing money and payments and
stuff and this is a very important area
and one that there's a lot of room for
for um
smart people to solve hard problems so
first why are Financial why are there
Financial interdependencies sorry if
this is too if this is belaboring the
obvious but you know there's a really
good reason for the financial World
Financial system to become highly
interconnected which is that to
efficiently allocate Capital Banks far
away need to deal with each other if I
could only borrow money for a to buy a
house from people with extra money in my
geographic area that would mortgages
would be a lot more expensive because
somewhere in South Korea there's people
with a ton of leftover money but maybe
no one around them wants to borrow it
and so
um Banks make contracts with each other
to you know if that kind of trade
happens through financial assets a bank
in South Korea having a bank having a
claim on a bank in you know uh Berkeley
to
get paid the returns for mortgages on
Berkeley houses and so that means that
distress can propagate through the
financial system when some of those
assets stop uh paying like they're
supposed to and it's a new and richer
type of contagion and my whole purpose
in this little chapter is just to show
you how much richer and more interesting
the problems get in kind of combining
some of the different things we've seen
um in intriguing ways so I'm going to
start with a little toy example built on
a paper with Matt Jackson and Matt
Elliott but it's a very it's we don't
take any credit for this this is an
exposition of a total econonical setup
of linear payment obligation so imagine
you have a bunch of Banks and each of
them owns some stuff a factory some
mortgage obligations that pay a flow of
Pi monies every every uh period and
what we're going to be curious about is
how these Banks end up exchanging these
assets effectively so we're going to
have cross Holdings where bank I
um is going to have a claim on a certain
percentage of Bank J so Bank Ben owns 20
of the Christian bank so cij is point
two
there's going to be no self claims and
the total amount of Christian to be
shared out is going to be less than a
hundred percent so there's going to be
some amount of Christian which is not
owned by other Banks but goes outside
the system to some rich family that owns
the Christian Bank okay and
so we're going to work with column
stochastic matrices here and there's the
share C hat is the share of claims on
Christian not promised to the rest of
the network but flowing outside and
um
that's that's the basic setup okay this
is just you know as simple as could be
let me show you so this is a picture
here the arrows reflect you know so Bank
One owns 0.8 of Bank two and the money
flows in the opposite direction that
means that when Bank C makes money it's
going to give 80 of it to Mr one to bank
one
any questions about the basics the very
basics of the setup yes
two ways there's no yeah they're the
only interesting things here basically
come from directing this that's that's a
very good you're a very good observation
um so let me
thank
you
so I own actually more than one so
exactly exactly so is I'm supposed to be
a bank who only has football
so I own more in the words and I
actually have money do I have to borrow
money to own that much yeah
exactly so this captures Financial
economists would say these are Equity
States so you bought equity in a bunch
of in a bunch of uh Banks and maybe that
Equity is actually more than your net
worth I guess where did you get that
maybe maybe you borrowed maybe you're
Donald Trump you went out and borrowed
money at high leverage and then bought
more Equity than your actual Network
which does happen you know
[Music]
[Music]
um so let's do something trivial I mean
hopefully this will I I just you know so
the reason I started with this toy model
is it gives you a ton of intuition for
free the question I can ask is what is
this big Christian Bank Worth right well
his Equity his value his total Equity
value will be equal to the assets he
directly claims the rent and mortgages
due to him or whatever but also
he's going to get value from the banks
the other banks that he owns
proportional to what share of them he
has a claim on cij times VJ that's the
basic equation that gives you a linear
system in asset values
solve the linear system you get a
description of what these banks are
ultimately what their total Equity value
is as a function of the fundamental
asset flows and they get somehow
redistributed they get allocated by the
by the system of cross Holdings let me
visually tell you to show you this in a
super baby example to emphasize you you
understand what's going on with that but
I wanna highlight one other thing which
is really what this system is is a is a
machine for sloshing around fundamental
returns taking money that comes from
mortgages and rent and delivering them
to other places now the the big V's that
we solved for are if you'd like the
equilibrium sizes of these hydraulic
nodes but it can be there's an inflation
phenomenon where actually the sum of the
v's can be bigger than the sum of the
fundamental assets and that actually
happens in equity markets in Japan and
France where you have a lot of these
loopy things going on Equity values if
you add them up are just way bigger than
the assets that underlie them if you
want to think of something more
conserved you can track the flow so
let's think of a little dollar that
falls on on bank one half that dollar
goes to bank two and now that's like 50
cents that fell on Bank two
and by the way the other half went out
immediately to the fundament to the rich
outside family that owns that that bank
so 50 has already been delivered to
Outsiders this 50 fell on Bank two 25
cents of it is delivered outside the
other 25 cents went back to bank one
which then you know so this sloshing you
can just think of this kind of hydraulic
system and ultimately of this dollar
that fell on bank one two-thirds of it
went out to the outsider outside owners
of bank one and the third of it got
allocated because of cross Holdings to
the outside holders of Bank two so
ultimately what this system gives you
once I pre-multiply by this these pipes
that deliver the funds outside it gives
you a column stochastic system that
tells you how
money flowing into the various Banks
gets all spread out to the ultimate
owners right so this system is is in
some you know it looks complicated when
you draw it but ultimately it's just
some kind of you know the money has to
go somewhere well this tells you where
it goes okay so haven't gotten to
anything too interesting yet
I guess we can you know so in a picture
you have the cylinders or the direct
asset values and they get sloshed around
and comprise different aspects of where
you know the fundamental values of these
or sorry the total values of these
various Banks so
um I'll put these slides up if you if
you would ever like to use this um
for a less mathematical audience
um but the point is that if you have a
shock to ease direct assets then that
shock will propagate to various degrees
to the various owners so if suddenly the
mortgages the you know a owns a bunch of
Bad Mortgages who stop paying they're
making their monthly payments now that's
going to have an impact on the rest of
the system
okay nothing too interesting going on
yet let's think about something a little
more interesting
the linear cross Holdings are too simple
if you want to model something like the
2008 crisis at least one Financial
contract that you must be interested in
can't help it is debt so Germans don't
like debt
um suppose I
oh so
Christian will be a creditor
Christian has lent me money a hundred
dollars
and here's my total my my wealth my
assets so if I have at least he's my
only creditor so if I have at least a
hundred dollars then I'm going to pay
him and his dependence on me is flat
right if I may he doesn't care whether I
have a thousand or two thousand dollars
but if I have less than a thousand
dollars he's a powerful creditor so he's
going to take all my assets to recover
as much debt as he can but because I
have less than a hundred dollars my
whole life you know he can't have his
whole hundred dollars so it's just gonna
be a linear function here so that looks
like this
exactly so this is what the value in
taking my wealth as the x-axis here or
my value my market value crisp the value
of Christians claim on me has this
kinked shape
so you need non-linear functions
immediately and so really in any
moderately realistic case you want to
have my goofy little linear system
you're going to have a non-linear system
where the market values of these firms
will be dependent in a non-linear way
like this through these debt contracts
on the market values of everyone else
and how much they can afford to pay
now coming back to lecture one by Matt J
if the V live in a complete lattice
and F is an isotone mapping so isotone
here means that when other people have
higher Market values they can pay more
of their obligations that's a very
natural assumption so you can take V you
can take the lattice structure on the
valuation space to be just the natural
partial ordering on RN
and you can many many natural financial
interdependencies and do some isotone f
well then we know that by tarsky's
theorem there's a complete lattice of
fixed points of this function and in
particular there is always at least one
consistent valuation in any such system
and actually Eisenberg and Noe which is
a very celebrated paper in the financial
networks literature kind of a Core paper
did the very interesting exercise of
setting f up I don't have time to do the
details but it set f up to represent
basically the actual rules of debt
clearing in normal Financial system
where for example debt is rationed
proportionally so if I owe three people
and I don't have enough to pay them all
I'll ration them proportionally to how
much I owe each of them so you put those
things in in the F system and they
actually found that under the natural
conditions there's a unique evaluation
Vector that's consistent for clearing
our debts in principle you could imagine
that exactly depending on the order and
the details of how you clear there might
be multiple Market values that that
clearing can induce but under standard
debt contracts they have a uniqueness
result by working with this lattice and
then using the structure of the ACT
actual debt contracts to deduce
uniqueness so I encourage you I don't
have time but I encourage you to look at
that paper and it kind of says that you
you can't get start getting into things
more more deep than linear functions
here but there's a bigger economic point
to make which is that even in a debt
case even when you know here this kind
of says well some of these like if I
don't have enough to pay depending on
where exactly Christian and I are in our
debt relationship that might hurt him or
not but ultimately if you have a
conservation life it's just about who
pays money to whom there's not an
economic efficiency implication really
of these debt clearing outcomes there's
a if less money is produced less value
is produced in the world than we hoped
it has to get allocated those losses
have to be pushed onto someone but
unless you put some mechanism of
amplification into the system right so
if f is sort of slope one if f is has a
conservation law you can't get welfare
consequences to be interesting because
it doesn't really matter you know for
the social planner to whom a dollar are
lost by me is just as bad as a dollar
lost by you it doesn't really matter how
exactly we clear this but yeah
he lives in a complete like this that I
think Tom's definition of this complete
ladies so where indeed this unique
evaluation factorial that is consistent
lies in this partial structure the
unique one I mean so in general we
complete lattice has a maximum and
minimum point and Eisenberg I know we
actually observed that and say well
suppose the maximum and minimum were
different and then they use the
properties of Maximum and minimal to
show that they're the same so there's
one fixed point it's kind of a magical
it's a it's a really neat piece of map
and it kind of says you know you can go
beyond I love these linear systems I can
solve them in one slide but
they show that you can really push the
trackability difference here to study
these you know much more interesting
objects but economists complain about
that lesser than a young complained
loudly they said these models are all
stupid because I didn't realize it was
being recorded on the volunteer
um these models have the flaw that they
are ultimately about just the
distribution of losses right and that's
that's not very interesting they they
studied even you know they allowed some
limited amplification but they said
under many of the models people were
studying these Financial contagion
questions just weren't fundamentally
that interesting because that you
couldn't get amplification of losses and
what you needed to add is some mechanism
for losses to create
other losses that might have been
avoided and so what's a natural what's a
natural model of that it's we call them
failure or Bank bankruptcy costs so if
you have fire sales of assets if you
have you know you have to sell off your
assets at bad prices to people who don't
even value them that much because you
need to raise cash that's very
inefficient misallocation of resources
so you know your managers instead of in
coming up with good business plans or
just trying to keep the company alive
that's a misallocation lawyer you have
to hire lawyers the biggest inefficiency
of all right so it's just wasted it's
just wasted effort shuffling paper when
companies have financial distress so
those you know what right this nice
paper in 2013 said you can take the
Eisenberg and Noe kind of debt clearing
model but now introduce a failure cost
that occurs when the value the market
value of a firm crosses a certain
threshold so when you go you know when
your creditor starts suing you for
example now you have to hire lawyers and
real resources get burned you have to
pay for them out of your company's value
so that now creates efficiency margins
which were absent in the pure sloshing
around model
and now you you actually do start to get
multiple equilibria you start getting a
lattice that's more interesting why
because so first of all I just want to
show you very quickly mathematically in
my linear model you can have these
failure costs you just take the same
system evaluation equations but you add
this loss
which is like you lose a chunk beta if
your value goes below
a threshold so this is still an isotone
system now you have because you can
prove that this is monotone it's better
if you survive but now you definitely
will have a non-trivial lattice and
you'll have
little no little VI is this thing um
little VI is
um C hat big V which is the thing that's
conserved but so
um
so
you can have real multiplicity here
where in some equilibria I have to pay
my bankruptcy costs because why because
you are paying me less than I was hoping
why because you are paying your
bankruptcy costs so our bankruptcies are
kind of self-reinforcing and another
equilibrium where neither of us would
have failed you're paying me because
you're solvent and therefore I'm I'm in
good shape and I'm solvent and I'm able
to pay you so you can get these
multiplicities
and now you can have minimal and maximal
equilibria where there's a best
equilibrium there's a worst equilibrium
and the lattice structure is very
similar if you were following Matt's
talk very similar to the kind of
structure that he analyzed there but now
richer in a sense because of course
where you know the slattus includes not
only this binary failure success thing
but the valuations the you know you can
think of the linear system right there's
that that kind of you have the discrete
plus the continuous interact interplay
and so I want to close this little
stanza by saying you have a mix of
continuous industry threshold
interdependence it's richer and closer
to the tractability boundary even
Eisenberg and know you have to be smart
to prove their uniqueness result and and
recently there's and I I really wanted
to get here and I'm glad I did
Ricky Vora who unfortunately was here
only one only for the Blackwell day has
beautiful recent work in which he
studies these Financial contagion models
and this paper is not yet released but
look out for it so it actually studies
these contagion models using stochastic
block graphons
um and and I think they can they're
pushing it to be more and more to really
make use of graph on techniques because
the point is you know these epidemic it
is kind of like an epidemic of contagion
but it's much more complicated than
anything we've looked at in the summer
school so far because it's or this this
Workshop it's not certainly not simple
epidemics because
whether you cause my bankruptcy really
depends on what's going on whether you
know they're not independent across
neighbors whether Christian is bankrupt
really affects how your bankruptcy
matters for me and you in fact have this
continuous part you know it's different
in different parts of the
um asset value space like depending on
exactly how much the fundamental assets
are worth that'll affect how close we
are to thresholds so it's this really
complicated threshold and
valuation system and I think it would be
too you know it's the fact that it comes
from the real Financial economy that
makes it worth studying and there's a
lot of Applied Physics questions and the
only way you can get any any grip on a
question like how big is going to be the
the bankrupt set in the best equilibrium
you have to have some you have to use
some graph on type techniques right
because in a fixed graph I mean what can
you say it's just some awful discrete
optimization problem but with graph on
structure you can hope to ask what's the
typical size of the surviving set right
and so these guys are working on that
and I think they're if you read their
paper you'll see just how wide open this
is in terms of being able to apply graph
on techniques to financial networks
problems okay so let me stop there with
I have my last half hour for my favorite
part but I want to make sure that if
there's anything any burning comments or
questions on this you had a chance to
thank you
go ahead
of the other values
over time so that is uh the typical
assumption like when I think about Banks
uh their value evaluation they change
over time
I was wondering that um
oh yes so my model of Bank valuation is
aesthetic fixed Point model and actually
that's even like how you know
okay nice thing about the financial
system is that people have pretty good
incentives to figure out what sentence
work quickly because if I'm holding
something that's not valued correctly
and I you know I would like to sell it
before everybody realizes that so there
are arguments that the financial system
has uniquely good reasons to reach a
fixed Point valuation vectors but I
actually think it's it is a pretty big
flaw there's sort of two extremes if you
read papers and pnas they use very naive
um there's literatures that use very
light physics models which don't take
into account you know the fact that
valuations are determined the
equilibrium few rational you know
Anticipation by agents and then you look
at economic models which have the
opposite problem that they assume that
the equilibrium somehow automatically
enacted as soon as the bats and values
are realized and thinking coming up with
good in between models that have someone
for you know Financial analysts running
their Excel spreadsheets but also
um don't assume that happens perfectly
or immediately I think that's that's
actually if it can be done well I think
be very much worth doing but that's a
caricature of two different ways of how
physicists versus Financial economists
um so this is a paper that just came out
it was an and I'm excited to talk about
it because it uses I hope that you'll
see as I said at the beginning that it
really tries to use Applied Physics type
ideas for
non-trivial economic
insights in about the supply chain covet
crisis the supply chain crisis the covet
triggered and so I want to
um talk about that a little bit
so
what's going on in this model is we're
going to study a complex production
economy where you have many steps of
production Each of which uses several
essential inputs so we're moving we're
moving Financial networks in some sense
the fundamental commodity flowing
through the system was extremely simple
it was just money and it was a question
of you know who had enough money in the
production production networks is the
part of Economics that studies in my
view the much more economically
important problem of you know it's the
most important economic Network how
firms buy stuff from other firms to make
stuff and so to the extent that they
rely on these links to get the inputs
they need you know the economic network
is the flow of value
between firms when they buy the stuff
they need and put it together into other
stuff but there's some real physics
there's some real physical production
happening which this network facilitates
and production Network the production
Network literature is about that
um
where it is right now is so the
economist vasilia leonty have studied
this in the 40s even before that
um as a network problem and
one thing that people but he studied it
at a very aggregated industry level and
something that's that I think is very
important in the actual economy is that
there's a lot of customization and firm
to firms don't just buy Commodities in
some big Anonymous markets they really
rely on other specific firms giving rise
to a very interesting Network so let me
give you a toy example we have a little
airplane manufacturer here and this
airplane manufacturer let's imagine that
they've sourced everything they need to
make airplanes except for two
Commodities which were brakes and
computers and they need to Source brakes
and computers in order to finish the
airplane
they have two Supply relationships with
brake manufacturers those are the people
that can give them they can't just go to
Home Depot and say oh give me your
brakes they need this customized you
know
um regulator cleared brake manufacturer
to give them their brakes and similarly
they can only buy their custom computers
from two firms that are potential
suppliers of their brakes
and this continues on you know so here
breaks maybe use disks and computer
chips maybe bought from some other firms
and this system branches out everywhere
it stops eventually but it has this
repeated branching structure and it
gives so this is a
a nun I'll just say from the beginning
this will give rise to a sort of
um
more comp it's not a certainly not a
viral kind of tree this tree it it I
don't even necessarily want you to think
of it exactly as a tree but there's
going to be some interesting Network
process going on on this
way
tell me
eventually have to buy some chips from
China which is common may be possible
Royale so we will have correlated yet
we'll capture that through correlated
shocks so I'm one thing actually so one
thing people do study in this literature
is you can imagine all this converges in
a kind of diamond to One Source like
Tyrone's chili machine manufacturers and
so that creates an obvious so that's an
important Point actually I wish I had a
slide on that Christian is saying that
you know maybe this this tree that looks
very bushy that I've drawn actually at
the end of the day converges to you know
Taiwanese chips okay and everybody's
dependent on this so that creates a huge
fragility because if Taiwanese chips
have a problem then the whole world
economy is screwed and that's an obvious
source of fragility which the network
economics literature has studied and
there's a beautiful econometric paper in
2012 by asamoglund co-authors called
um the network origins of uh
yeah Network origins of volatility or
something which is about that kind of
effect and I want to tell you that
there's a different reason even in the
world
with other fragilities which are maybe
worse okay so so I kind of want to know
there's this fragility and there's going
to be another one we have a lot of great
empirical evidence that firms are very
sensitive to the performance of specific
counterparties so when your supplier
goes under you know old school economics
would say oh no problem there's a big
market I'll find another supplier in
fact that takes a while and
um real economic losses are sustained
due to idiosyncratic breakage of these
links of course firms are not stupid
they understand that they're reliant on
their suppliers and that's why they
multi-source and have many options
there's two in this example but they're
going to have multiple options of
getting their goods
and so what I want to ask is how robust
is a network so you you wanted a sort of
correlated Christian was interested in
this like everybody's dependent on this
one node but another thing that we might
be worried about is that there are
certain things that shape the
performance of this entire network all
at once so if you have a phenomenon like
shipping congestion
the world shipping lanes get clogged up
and I'll talk more about that that it's
going to make it less likely that each
of these relationships function
successfully it's going to make
everybody hard it's going to make it
harder for everybody to get their
deliveries on time
exactly so that's I mean right I think
the Suez Canal was still an
idiosyncratic event it was more I'll
tell you in a second what how I think of
the corporate situation at least as a
character truth but what we want to
understand I guess you know from the
Applied Physics perspective when we have
the system which is going to be this
network which we're hoping will function
but which will be percolated by the
failures induced by shipping ingestion
and other problems
how hopeful can we be that the system
will work
um and what we'll find is that this
system is susceptible to discontinuous
phase transitions where when you have a
fairly small shock to the world shipping
system quality the many unrelated Supply
networks can simultaneously freeze up
and and have bad problems and this is
not just a possibility I don't know if
I'll get to this but I'll at least claim
it before we stop that this is not just
something that can happen in the physics
there's it's not just that there's a
place in this phase kind of
you know space of outcomes where stuff
can be bad like this but that fragility
is something that the system comes to
naturally because of the optimization of
the agents within it so
yeah
exactly there is and I think this is one
of this might be I it's
it's a fully it's a it's a model built
to satisfy economists we're
self-organized criticality comes about
in National equilibrium what firms
invest in trying to make these links
work that's kind of the one slide
overview of the paper so let me tell you
a little more about how it works before
I get to that let me tell you how I
think of applying it to the actual
economy so
the covet shot
you might have read you know I don't
know if you know this but the world
shipping Network actually performed
amazingly well during covet it the
throughput of stuff was bigger than the
previous year the problem is people
wanted to put so much stuff through it
demand shifted people bought a lot more
stuff on Amazon and a lot fewer meals at
restaurants and their the shipping
system tried its best but it was
congested and so anything you were
hoping to get uh from your suppliers
would likely be delayed and more
stochastic in its arrival and that was
really the shock to the system
um and so
recently macroeconomists and there's a
tragically
um
died in in 2020 Emmanuel Farr he had
amazing work with David bakayi about
taking macroeconomic models and making
them richer in studying firm to firm
relationships very much in the spirit of
those financial Network interdependency
models I showed you
um but suited to the macro economy but
those models always end up being smooth
especially in the aggregate in the end
macroeconomists love to take a system
and write down some aggregate some
function some differentiable function
which is going to tell you in the
aggregate how do shocks to uh shipping
quality firm productivity whatever
translate into outcomes they love a
differentiable system but we think
because we're we because I like graph
theory in percolation I think some of
the most interesting stuff can be where
it's not continuous and this paper is an
effort to to
um tell that story to bring
discontinuous effects into these
macroeconomic models so let me tell you
more about the model starting with a
single Supply tree again so in the real
in the whole economy we're going to have
many of these Supply trees knit together
and interacting but I don't want to
focus on one this little airplane
manufacturer it has
a typical firm any firm in this network
but let's say this airplane firm in
order to produce it needs to procure
several inputs let's say breaks and
computers here it has multiple sources
of each input and each of these dotted
lines will work independently with
probability X okay
so the suppliers are in a very similar
situation but one step less deep and
then at some point when you get to the
most Upstream these people maybe they
use raw materials maybe they can buy
their stuff on some commodity Market but
they're not reliant on on this stuff
they're not reliant on these fragile
disruptible Supply relationships and so
what I'm going to be interested in and
actually you can you can
if you're a physicist I can just tell
you what I what I'm really interested is
studying this object that I call
reliability which is How likely is this
firm to be able to produce right so let
me show you that in a in a sort of
illustration dotted lines are what
relationships can function and then
we're going to do the percolation and
we're going to keep only some of the
dotted lines independently with
probability X and then we'll ask Mr
airplane manufacturer can you make your
airplane let's figure that out
and let's figure it out starting from
Upstream from the from the so look at
this input of the brake manufacturer
unfortunately both links that could be
used to ship that input are not working
those chips won't get there in time so
for this period this brake manufacturer
can't get this essential input called G
and will turn him pink to indicate that
therefore they can't function don't need
to think about anything else now once
this brake manufacturer is unable to
deliver actually that shipping link
would have worked that ship would have
made it on time but unfortunately
there's nothing to put in it right now
because this period breaks are not
working and this [ __ ] this guy has
brakes but that chipping link is not
working
and so our hero A1 here is not able to
produce because can't Source breaks
right so we solved it from the top and
we found that by by iteratively doing
this kind of so you see it's not going
to boil down to something simple like is
there a connected component or something
it's one of these things that comes up
in more like bootstrap percolation type
type uh stuff that that because of this
complex dependence on multiple things
happening at once so of course
reliability depends on depth depth of
this tree here is two steps right if I
made it taller it would change the
calculation and we're interested in how
reliability is going to depend I mean
I'll preview eventually depth we're
gonna be interested in depth being big
so really complex Supply chains but
we're going to be interested in how
reliability depends on X on the quality
of the shipping links and we call that
relationship strength the probability
that any given relationship delivers and
gives you the stuff you wanted
so okay now I'm going to tell you how we
knit together so ultimately we're going
to be about the Applied Physics study of
role I'm going to tell you very briefly
how that knits together into an economy
and if you you know many of your
economists so you're interested in this
but it but
um I'll make it I'll I'll make this part
high level just tell you what what how
we create a whole economy so we have a
finite set of products airplanes brakes
computers each of these products is
populated by a Continuum of small firms
that produce airplanes so unlike a lot
of classic Network science we're not
interested in this big lumpy firm that
if it fails the whole world all firms
are small here the problems are going to
be systemic not lumpy individualized
central people problems
so there's a Continuum of small firms
for example 8.1 is the airplane firm
whose label is so the firms here are
labeled right and so we have a Continuum
of firms in uh industry number one which
which I'm gonna make index them by you
know real numbers between zero and one
so a Continuum of firms
and each firm in a given type of product
needs to Source a certain list of inputs
to produce so if you're making airplanes
you need breaks in computers actually
more but I'm keeping the examples simple
and every firm here is going to have a
depth associated with it which is the
number of steps it needs in order to
generate
it's um the number of of steps of
production the depth of the supply
network and it can even be different
within the same product so maybe Mr one
can need three steps but Mr four is more
more sophisticated and needs to Source
in four steps okay
and there's going to be some kind of
distribution of depths in the whole
economy which we're going to take to be
supported on big depths so we can
imagine depths are poisson with a mean
of 17 okay that's how I'm going to draw
some of my pictures so those are the
those are the the basics and what's
going to happen is
so this is really these are really The
Primitives of some graph on like object
right because what I'm going to do is
I'm going to take this Continuum and I'm
going to create
I shouldn't call it a graph on actually
I'm just going to create a graph on a
Continuum of nodes we'll get to the
graph on kind of
thoughts later there's a graph on the
set of this Continuum of nodes so the
Continuum of airplane firms break firms
there's going to be these directed
dotted lines the potential Supply links
and I'm going to build this random graph
in a very hokey goofy way okay what I'm
going to do is I'm just going to say if
you're a depth 3 guy what you're going
to do well you so in general I'll say
we'll work at the model where you need
everybody needs the same number of
distinct inputs so everybody needs to
combine seven different things
um for everything that they need they're
going to draw end potential suppliers of
that thing and they're just going to
sample them in some atomless way from
the Continuum of people who are capable
of supplying them so those suppliers
have to have compatible depth if I'm a
depth three guy I need a depth 2 guy and
they have to be making the thing I want
right and I'm just going to draw them
one way or another and so this Continuum
object is a little messy to think about
but the only things that will ever
matter for the functionality of a given
firm is a countable set of random
variables which is everything Upstream
of me right so
even even finite even finite so I so
that's my question are you eating
because in economics we sometimes do our
youth sometimes to just have particular
players available
or I think of sort of having fun at
large and maybe drawn from that
Continuum or maybe converge into this so
what is your their model here so in the
spirit of so my model here is we we do
not so okay I personally am extremely
interested in the finite approximation
question but here the firms there will
be a Continuum and you won't take a
finite then for how how many forms there
are but we will keep something finite
which is the depth will never work with
anything infinite depth everything will
always depend on what we find at many
steps but this distribution of depths
might be mostly on large depths right
but it will be large finite gifts so
those are the limits we'll take but I
think it's extremely interesting and
it's a question I want to ask about you
how would these models actually work in
the approximation could you could you
prove that what I'm about to tell you
using the Continuum would be true of
sufficiently large models and I think
here
um I hope
can you help me in hey
yeah yeah talk yesterday was uh was
extremely relevant because I hope to get
theorems like that that there's that the
the you know there's structure here in
the limit which you could write you
could write down fixed Point equations
that hold at the limit and I think it
should be possible to say that that
would in fact approximate a large finite
realization of this
um and I I don't I think I'm very
interested in those kinds of questions
so let me so basically you create this
big you know I showed you one tree but
these trees will all interact and Source
from each other it may be that for
example you know this airplane
manufacturer and some other airplane
manufacturer both rely on the same brake
guy that can happen in the graph and
that's fine you know that will happen
um and I'm going to skip so
yeah but actually it's a poisson the
incoming links are a poisson process so
you sort of like the number of incoming
links that were in you will be passed on
with the means
so
and then we're going to take this
continuing graph and we're going to
percolate it we're going to need a
fraction of the links we're going to
only keep links with probability X
independently okay and so
um I'm going to skip the economics and
say and just promise you that we worked
hard to work out an economic model where
what matters is ultimately for economic
welfare for the amount of goods produced
what matters is the fraction of
functioning firms some of these firms
are going to be able to work some won't
be and you can write ultimate GDP as a
fraction as a increasing function of the
fraction of firms that can work that's
called a lover variety model consumers
in this world will love more types of
firms to work because they you know the
more firms we have the more different
customized stuff they can make and that
consumer likes that so ultimately what
the welfare relevant outcome in this
model is Rogue and now I can tell you my
favorite thing okay I can tell you what
role looks like so what am I interested
in uh so first you can you can you can
figure out growth in this mode you can
figure out Row for any depth of firm
using exactly the little calculation the
little picture I showed you and then you
can average across those various rows
well you can average across the
different depth reliabilities
weighted by how many of those firms
there are for each duct and get an
average role in the economy which is the
fraction of firms that can function
and
what I want to show you is this picture
that as I'm so here I fixed a
distribution over rows say it's possum
with average 20 I think and I'm plotting
the reliability of the economy as a
function of the common relationship
strength okay so I'm varying X for
everyone and you see when X is you know
0.3 very little can be produced when X
is 0.6 you're almost in full reliable
it's a very sharp transition and if you
take average depth bigger and bigger and
look at the limit as deaths are big
you're going to get a picture like this
you're going to get a precipice where
there's a critical level of relationship
strength below which reliability is zero
and above which reliability is above a
pretty high in this case it's above a
half above a critical level so suddenly
when relationship strength crosses a
threshold you're suddenly able to
produce a lot and under it you're able
so it's extremely sensitive there right
little shocks if you happen to be here
tiny shocks to X can really destroy the
productive capacity of your economy now
you might think
surprised nobody's asked me does that
depend on X being so homogeneous
throughout the economy turns out it
doesn't you can it would it should be
you rather than me writing down this
model because you would do it so much
more nicely but you can consider a model
with very rich variation more like a
general kind of you know the analog of
your of in your talk the general kind of
expander object you don't need any of
the much of the homogeneity that I said
for this part you can have X is very
different across different parts of the
graph what matters is that if there's a
correlated shock which lowers many X's
simultaneously
you will have a sharp transition like
this okay
okay
spend that much money very good so
Christian has anticipated
that's exactly what the rest of my talk
is about before we get there I want to
draw a contrast okay
you could consider a different process
which will
now make contact with your graph
theoretic intuition you can consider
what I call the process of simple
production what's how is simple
different from my process simple means
that in each step of production people
only need to Source One thing people
only need to go out and find one
supplier of a fragile of a with those
there's only one good that you need to
Source through these disruptible
relationships anything else you can buy
on commodity markets which are reliable
if that's true then this everything
until boils down to the analysis
basically of a giant component and the
theory the size of the reliabilities
that you know the reliability function
will be an increasing continuous
function of relationship strength there
will be a kink but it has nothing like
this crazy behavior so the precipice
requires complexity everybody trying to
Source two things and combine them at
every step so it's more of a complex
contagion phenomenon but Christian asks
sort of the money question the very uh
you know
economics sequestion which is why would
we ever be here it seems very
inefficient to be here and if you had
you know how would we think about the
incentives of firms
determining whether we are in fact in a
fragile situation or whether we managed
to
invest our way out of it by investing
because remember when firms invest if
now you view X as a choice and firms can
increase their X
it sure seems like it would be better
not to be right here where a tiny little
shock to the
shipping system you know knocks out our
whole supply network so what so if I
hope to really make this a theory of why
fragility happens rather than just a
little physics fact I'd better explain
what's going on with that let me quickly
let me I want to show you just in in one
slide maybe I want to show you why the
discontinuity arises
so let me give you a little
undergraduate exercise suppose that
on the x-axis here we have the
reliability of your suppliers just
imagine that all my suppliers work
independently with probability R so I
need I I just think of this 2-2 example
I was giving you I have two suppliers
for for each of two things and
independently each of my suppliers are
available are able to make their thing
with probability R what's the
probability that I can make my thing
that I can make my thing right well I
won't we don't have time for me to work
through this but I'm extremely sure that
you could calculate you know there are M
different things you need M different
types of things you need to Source each
of them is operational with probability
R but then the link also needs to work
that happens with probability X so this
is the function that gives you your
reliability as a function of your
suppliers reliability
and it turns out that for all X except
the critical X
you can you can it's not hard to
convince yourself that the reliability
of the system will be given for deep
networks will be given by the largest
fixed point of this map because in a
deep system your suppliers look just
like you they basically have a deep
supply network extending from them that
they need to Source from so whatever
your reliability is theirs is going to
be very similar and in order for it to
be positive there needs to be like a POS
it's actually going to be the largest
fixed point so you end up with
the largest fixed Point here uh and now
of course it's all about now this this
whole curve depends on x so as I change
X I'm going to change this whole curve
and you can see where the discontinuity
is going to come from but let me so let
me run through that the discontinuity
comes from when I lower X when I lower
this whole curve by lowering the link
success by percolating my system more
and more severely
the the this curve relating me and my
suppliers is going to descend to send
descend Ascend you've seen this picture
in other contexts and it's gonna
so every time I've been plotting the fix
the reliability at the fixed point and
then at some point it just disappears
right so that's where criticality
happens and it's really the the complex
contagion nature of this process the
fact that I need multiple good things to
happen at the same time is what makes
this curve so shallow here and rules out
the possibility of a fixed point near
zero okay so that's the physics of it
but Christian is anxious here for the
economics so let me give you you know of
course we can't do we can't do this
properly but I'm going to spend my last
five to seven minutes on telling you why
we think this is not just a curiosity
but an economic problem okay so now
we're going to let each firm choose the
level of its investment we're going to
let each firm choose X more more
formally before the supply network is
realized we're going to let each firm
choose a number xif which is the
probability that its links the ones that
it uses to Source are going to work so I
can have any probability I want but of
course not for free
I'm gonna have a cost function that
determines my probability my my the cost
of achieving a given level of
reliability of my Supply links
um and we're going to make some
regularity assumptions on this we're
going to assume it's very expensive to
get perfect reliability of your links
that's called in another condition and
then if a firm produces I need to you
know it's a little bit of an annoying
thing about economic models that you
need to specify all these details but
when a firm produces it's going to earn
a certain profit
after you know growth of this investment
is going to earn a profit which depends
on how much competition it faces so I'm
going to build something into the model
which makes it so that when more of my
let me say it the other way when fewer
of the people producing my same thing
are active I'm going to be able to
charge a higher markup and make more
money so G will be a function that's
decreasing and how many of my
competitors are able to produce okay and
Kappa will be a productivity parameter
that I'll just shift around to make the
economy more or less productive Okay so
I'll just reiterate a question that was
asked
I claim to you that it's you know if
we're right at this critical point life
will be extremely bad and there will be
a big risk of a little shock to the
shipping system screwing us but the
question is would we want to be at this
point well first of all if relationship
strengths are chosen in some random way
maybe the system will be unproductive
maybe it'll be very productive but it's
very non-generic to end up right here
and it's certainly inefficient to end up
here because if a planner were setting
all of our X's the planner would say hey
guys
if all of you invest just a little more
X you'll get an infinite kick to
reliability at the margin that's going
to cause some finite amount don't do
that that's stupid invest a little more
okay
but I'll tell you that when relationship
strengths are chosen in equilibrium
there's a non there's a phenomenon
that's not knife edge where they do end
up on the precipice and that's the last
picture I'll show and then we'll stop
so
I'm going to Define for you just in
words what an equilibrium means
everybody invests according to this
investment game and when they're
investing they're taking for granted the
reliability created by others
Investments and I'm going to look for a
symmetric equilibrium so everybody's
investing X and I think about that I'm
like okay well Francesca is going to be
reliable you know 52 of the time that
determines how much profits I make when
I produce I think about how my
investment affects my probability of
sourcing the thing I need which is a
little problem you work out on the side
and I optimize taking for granted
everybody's reliability
um and choose the optimal level of
reliability for me let me show you what
that looks like in a picture
you can draw a best response curve which
says how much I want to invest the way
you should read this curve is you should
look on the on the vertical axis and say
if my competitors are and my suppliers
by the way right are working with
probability R what's an optimal level of
investment for me in some numbers so for
example when everybody else is very
unreliable when they're not working
there's no point in investing because
you're not going to get anything right
so you might as well go home and sleep
if everybody's very reliable there's
actually not going to be a great
rationale for investing too much either
because
um it of course it depends on the cost
function but it's gonna incentives here
are going to fall off because when my
when my neighbors are very productive I
don't need many links to work in order
to Source stuff so there's going to be
some interesting shape to this doesn't
matter that much but as I increase Kappa
which is the productivity multiplier
which makes it more valuable to produce
and makes me want to invest more this
curve this best response Curve will
slowly shift up and the point is there's
a whole open set of parameters here
where that curve is intersecting by the
way what is this green thing it's
imagine I picked Tau to be some very
high but finite number like depth a
thousand right it's going to look
basically vertical in the picture but
it's actually going to be an honest
increasing function and the best
response curve is going to intersect
somewhere and this is the equilibrium
this is the efficient equilibrium of the
economy where the
so I'll let me explain what the
intersection intersection is
everybody's investment determines
reliability that's how the physics of
the system works but given everybody's
reliability it tells people what
investment they want to choose and an
equilibrium is where those two things
coincide and when we choose the high one
we're avoiding sort of a stupid
miscoordination right but you can see
that there's a whole open set of Kappa
where equilibrium is on the precipice
and the problem that what's going on
there is even though individually we
would it would be better if we all
invested more when I invest more I
there's a big externality because I
improve my own productivity but I also
give profits to all these people
Upstream of me whose profits I don't
Downstream of me whose profits I don't
directly enjoy and so I underinvest and
even if people anticipated the small
shock that's going to knock the system
off the precipice and break productivity
that wouldn't be enough like imagine
imagine that people said oh but X might
get shocked downward and we should worry
about that even if they were worrying
about that it would only change their
best responses a little bit that's a
continuous transformation to the game it
wouldn't fundamentally change the fact
that they can be on the precipice for
quite a few values of Kappa
eventually
one hour which we saw before so if you
have different competitors would have
different laws yes so if so so leaving
you actually so this is an equilibrium
which is really bad yes but maybe in
your lanterns of equilibrium because
there's one where different people do
differences that stabilizer system
perfect so I'll let in it to happen so
this I don't I won't tell you any
anything I have done here with what I
wanted to say I think the the questions
that are important at this stage are a
few first how restrictive is the
Assumption of symmetric equilibrium
which I just enforced right you could
ask it's a hard math question if now
different even in a symmetric Network
and you can even consider you can you
can consider even a perfectly symmetric
Network where everybody has an infinite
tree above them you're like the lattices
you were drawing yesterday is it are the
symmetric equilibria the only equilibria
I don't know and that's a question that
that uh might that I think is
mathematically very interesting and then
there's a separate question which is if
the system is you know I've you can see
why I made my example so homogeneous
everybody has the same M same n so that
I could draw everything in this one
dimensional curve and it made sense for
all everybody to be characterized by one
number but I think very much in the
spirit of jagannist talk yesterday I
would like of course to have an
arbitrarily Rich object that would allow
a lot of diversity in those things and I
would like an analog of this limit uh
fixed Point problem that would only use
the sort of data that's in the tail
Sigma algebra but that would be
predictive of what would happen in you
know large finite systems realized
according to this and it you know as you
can as you can imagine there will be
some unreasonably tricky geometry
problem to figure out the analog of
ending up in this critical space and
there will be questions in probability
how do you define the limit objects how
do you so I think we've worked out this
toy you know the fun thing about being
an economist is you can do the
one-dimensional toy example uh and and
um get smarter people excited about
doing the the deeper and richer examples
but I think there is a lot you know
maybe the ultimate point is that the
mechanics built in to whether a node can
be productive are economically
interesting and they give rise to new
problems in applied probability you know
of how you know how exactly these curves
will look
um what equilibria would look like in
less symmetric systems and so I think
you know I'm very excited about those
I'm thinking about some of them would
love to talk about them and I'll stop
there and
um thank you very much for your
questions and your attention
thank you so much quick question we had
a few duration
and I'll Stick Around
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
very good
yeah you can do so
I'll tell you why we did extraordination
because in economics there's a large
literature on investing in relationships
I mean I'm a network side so to me
there's a lot of economists are
interested in people investing in their
relationships doing things to make it
more likely under underlying these
things there's Dynamic models of us
interacting over time and I might have
the chance to run away with your money
or screw you in some way and I might not
you know if we have a better
relationship it means that we have a
stronger you know good relationships
that doesn't happen right so we wanted
for economic reasons we wanted to think
of the endogenous investment being to
strengthen one's relationships but
you're completely right that in actually
the physics is actually a lot simpler if
you do node percolation it's just the so
so we there's a and I should say Matt
and I have written a survey called
networks and economic fragility where we
do the notification version which is
easier but there's no fundamental that
my explanation is the whole reason
because we wanted to think about a game
of investing in the links of a and by
the way I think graphones can be great
for this because when you solve these
Network formation games and discrete
settings they can be possible but in
this kind of continual setting the
network investment problem is just down
to one number right and so I like that
smoothness and I want to push that as a
method that people can use to simplify
the information fields
I want to just elaborate a little bit on
that question maybe I have to analyze in
general
that maybe you could have just two
accidents they have a sort of half of
your network does sort of
puts a little r and the other half puts
a larger and now you would have to see
maybe that equivalent would actually not
yes so my guess is that in the
symmetrical environment there are only
symmetric equilibrium but I don't know
how to and my smart student Krishna
dasarata wrote a paper about a related
environment and kind of the hardest
proof in this paper was about proving
about getting rid of asymmetric
equilibrium so it can be a bear but I
think it's exactly you consider two of
them you see whether there's some
contractions to get rid of it but
there's there's
foreign